you always have an interesting take on
what's happening in the world the first
question everyone talking about voter
turnout did you vote yesterday yes I did
you did good for you yes like they got a
vote excited I can't quite remember who
I voted for the president
uh-huh it wasn't Trump or Hillary though
yeah like either one of them really you
didn't like either one no I didn't I
couldn't stand her she dresses like a
real estate agent like girthy it's doing
this thing with a head yeah the other
guys saying take people's coats yeah
they just didn't offer anything for me
yeah so they weren't they didn't appeal
to you no they didn't I I don't
understand why everybody's so upset yeah
you know like what's gonna happen to you
do you like the Obama did he call you at
all in the last eight years
did he ever put a sandwich on your table
you do that you're gonna keep doing that
you're gonna be fine right dude I have
to say though him winning is the most
astounding thing I've ever seen it was a
surprise with me surprise dude like
you're talking like like Lake Placid the
Olympics when we beat the Russian berry
set Kirk Gibson's home run is a joke
right
the Giants beat the undefeated Patriots
that's all a joke though the star of a
reality show is gonna run the country
like I've decided if Bret Michaels or
Cindy Lauper would make a better CEO for
a company that doesn't exist
it's unbelievable yeah he was the [ __ ]
though he was like he just reminded me
like when I didn't read the book and I'm
just like just winging it you know how
you gonna do that you'll see you'll see
did it worked
dude he is the greatest [ __ ] talker of
all time he's said it like $100,000
breakfast well the president trashed him
because you familia tis a couple of
years ago yeah jumping around House
Correspondents Dinner yeah thank you
thanks for giving structure yeah
humiliated the guy right my wife would
love you yeah next to me during brunch
she never knows what I'm saying yeah
yeah the guy totally trashes him he's
absolutely humiliated and within like
two three years he had that guy's jump
right so you could never talk you could
never talk [ __ ] to him gonna say darling
you know one time I was in a bar and
this guy came in yeah take me oh really
one time I was sitting I paid a hundred
grand for breakfast the president Trump
president the hell's his name Barack
Obama yeah yeah I'm giving you structure
now Obama he trashed me two years later
and jump
[Applause]
out of his house well how did you think
the night would go did not Hillary was
gonna kill ya I totally did I was
sitting there going like yeah you know
that I mean I thought he was gonna do
okay but then it was unbelievable it's
like one of those things like you're
watching a game and you don't care who
wins you know what I mean you know I I'm
just hoping it's gonna be a good game
and then all of a sudden you know the if
one team's up by like 30 you're thinking
and then he just came in any I don't
know the Statue of Liberty I don't know
it's astounding are you worried about
him at all being in office so you think
you mean is it does it concern you I
don't know I feel like the president you
only see him like once every three weeks
you know if you like me with dating a
chicken she was a jerk but you only saw
her once every three weeks there's like
no way she could break your heart you
know what people date and they'd like
their day to day yeah well what do you
think his presidency is gonna be like
you know a forecast for us what's it
gonna be like I I have no idea I have no
idea all I know is the other one used to
go to those Bilderberg meetings you know
where they'll dress up like yaks and
have those Eyes Wide Shut parties so I
didn't know what she was gonna do wait
Hillary Clinton oh yeah what are you
talking about that meaning they have
underneath the mountain what are you - I
got you out here to bring perspective
and now and yeah this is madness I don't
know if she dresses like it's under a
mountain what do you want me to say like
this whole thing the whole thing none of
it none of it makes sense like this guy
saying he's gonna build a wall from
California to like El Paso Texas like
dude I've done that drive that's like a
two-day drive 85 miles an hour like
you're gonna fill the wall you're really
gonna do this like how much is this
gonna cost how many times you're gonna
go to Home Depot
look how long it took to build the
Freedom Tower we wanted that that took
15 years dude by the time they build
that thing we're gonna be the ones going
over it
[Applause]
no I'm not I'm not like you know well
how could the poles be so wrong that's a
big question everyone's asking today's
the polls all said Oh Hillary 95% it's
85% chance how could that have done so
guys I don't think that they talk to
people I think they just hang out in
their conference room again you feel
without them 47% when did they do it no
one has ever asked me and I also think
if you're any sort of a normal person
it's just somebody came walking up to
you with a clipboard like hey uh who you
vote for present people either so stupid
or just with so much free time that they
would sit there and they would talk to
somebody with a clipboard I like I would
never do that and they would probably
say whatever comes to mind Yeah right
yeah truth exactly fascinating stuff
we're gonna take a break
much more with Bill burr around
you